okay audience questions good ones this
week I hope that I'm not portrayed as
completely out of touch with teenager
culture as a result of this first
question from Lily who asked what do you
think of the whole fidget spinner
phenomenon are you concerned about the
youth growing up in the Trump era or
tech era
or do you think it's just natural for
older people to think whatever the kids
are doing is wrong
so first of all do I understand the
fidgets phenomenon and that these are
basically it's sort of equivalent to a
stress ball it's just something else to
sort of physically occupy one's hands
it's a bit of a stress release device I
mean is that that's what these spinners
are I don't really know but it looks
like maybe you put your fingers in the
three holes or you can I guess lock them
together in some pattern or yeah why not
I mean yeah Brian am I right about that
that's what fidget spinners are right
your basic it's basically like a stress
ball that you're messing with yeah I
think that that's fine what do I think
about it I think it's a new version of a
stress ball or one of those hand you
know remember those things where it's
like a almost like a clamp that you need
strength in order to depress and well
you work out your arms you work out your
legs and your abs might as well not your
hand yeah I'm I have no problem with
these fidget spinners although it is
weird when you walk by a group of young
kids and they're just sitting there
spinning these things as fast as they
possibly can I just don't really care
that much it doesn't really appeal to me
I've got a couple stress balls at my
desk at home and I don't really ever
pick them up they've kind of like you
know but you have something on your desk
for so long it blends into the
background and you don't notice it
anymore it's kind of like that I mean I
think my bigger concern with the Trump
era slash tech era and kids is when I
see really young kids who seem to only
be able to have a reasonable attention
span when they've got a screen in front
of them that is a concern to me and like
I don't have a kid to quote a former
producer Louis if I accidentally had a
kid I'd probably love the kid I would
even go further to say I definitely love
the kid accidental or otherwise I would
be very hesitant to put a screen in
front of my kid I would say four years I
think that the whole thing about parents
just thinking that their their kids are
doing something
that's going to be counter to their
intelligence or what have you yeah it's
pretty ludicrous honestly especially
because it just eliminates the idea that
technology can be good for us I mean you
can learn plenty of things online okay
your news on there I don't disagree with
that but I've just seen so many kids and
I genuinely don't know if there's
research behind this I have more and
more friends that have kids
and they're I totally get it like hey
listen I've got my kids with me we're
going out to a coffee shop I want to
just be able to have them pay attention
to something and not bother us so I'm
going to have them watch a movie with
headphones on their iPad but when I go
to people's homes and the kids are just
sitting on on technology and screens for
hours and I see that they really don't
seem to be as interested in anything
else
puzzles books outside stuff there's got
to be something that's bad about that
right I mean that can't possibly be good
I guess well I only have to know in time
right but I think with these little
tinker toy things whatever they're
called fidget spinners fidget spinners
they don't seem too bad to me I mean
it's just the same thing as maybe
baseball cards where decades ago and in
my generation we had pokemon cards and
beyblades how is it any different yeah
well I guess it's pretty similar to that
yeah I again this is why I'm not
concerned about fidget spinners I've got
there's lower hanging fruit that I would
want to tackle all right Lily